Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're gonna go ahead
and take a look at virtual shadow maps
and how to edit them and how they work overall
when working with Lumen.
So let's get started.
So virtual shadow maps, what they do is update
on the fly and they significantly increases
shadow resolution to match highly detailed nanite geometry.
Unlike shadow maps, which is the old baking method,
which are like texture projecting.
So it's basically what you would do in the old way
of working with Unreal with lighting and baking,
you would bake your lights and the shadow would be baked
upon a static piece of geometry.
And you would, if you move that geometry,
you would actually see that shadow still there
and you would have to rebake for it to update
on a static light in your environment and static geometry.
So plausible soft shadows with reasonable,
controllable performance causes what it gives you.
Provide a simple solution, it provides that,
that works by default with limited amounts
of adjustment needed.
So out of the box, it works really well.
I'm gonna give you a few tips and tricks
to be able to adjust those shadows if you need to,
but out of the box, it works really well
and you'll probably very rare occasions
have to edit things.
Replace the many stationary light shadowing techniques
with a single unified path.
So in the old days,
we'd have multiple stationary lights.
Basically they allowed your object to move
and in that object moving,
you would get some soft degrading shadows
and you would have to rebake anytime you adjusted
some of your static objects.
And it would just, it was a lot of work
and it was a simplistic type of answer
to working with Unreal, but now working with Lumen,
everything can be updated on the fly.
Now, remember your lights need to be movable
when you're setting this and you need to make sure
that your virtual shadow maps are on.
By default, they do come on, but if you're inheriting,
if you're inheriting an older scene,
you need to double check that
and make sure that they're on.
And you'll see this here where you can actually
look it up in your project settings
and simply just make sure your virtual shadow maps
are on.
So again, Lumen is made for virtual shadow maps.
Virtual shadows do not work in a baking scenario.
You would have to set things to light maps.
So it's not intended for Unreal standard baking.
If you want to switch to baking,
you must change your shadow settings, as you see here.
Let's go ahead and move on.
So break things down, to break things out a little
further, virtual textures deal with similar issues.
Virtual shadow maps handles shadows similarly.
And what that means is it only calls up,
brings up the visual fidelity,
the highest quality pieces of those shadows.
You can think of it like textures,
but of the shadow,
when your camera is in that particular region or area.
So virtual textures splits the texture
and MIP chain into tiles and streams it in only,
when the only ones needed.
So it's kind of the same thing
when it comes to virtual shadow maps.
Local lights, you'll see here,
it says 16K by 16K virtual resolution with eight MIPs.
Spotlights use a single virtual shadow map.
Point light, point and rec lights,
each use six virtual shadow maps, one per cubic face.
2K more than conventional shadow maps in Unreal, baked.
Can still run out if you make massive local lights.
Now that has changed so that now we have mega lights.
Now we get into mega lights
in our atmospheric lighting course.
Now remember, it's still experimental in beta,
but that allows you to not hit that cap so quickly
and hit that performance cap
so that you can actually add as much as you need.
A lights and your geometry work really nice together.
But again, it is experimental,
but it is way better than the old baking method
and your visual fidelity will come up as you need it
based on the position of your camera in the world.
So you'll see here, spotlight on the side here.
Let me pulse my cursor.
Spotlight virtual pages, visualization and editor.
You can see that here,
and we're gonna go over the visualizers in just a bit.
Each of these pages maps to a tile
in one of the virtual shadow map mip levels.
Only virtual pages needed by the camera view
need to be allocated and rendered into the physical pages.
So again, it's like bringing up what you need
when you need it and not drawing everything
at the same time.
Pretty convenient and you get a more realistic shadow
when doing so.
Here's a further breakdown to explain that process.
So what you see here, we have a directional light 16K,
so nowhere near enough resolution.
LED takes advantage of the camera projection expanding.
You can see here,
we have a directional light camera projection expanding.
You can see the graphical sample here showing that,
and you can see a clip map demonstration here
and how that works.
Show shadow comparison.
Mip maps all cover the same world area,
but half the resolution.
So that's kind of the old way.
Clip map levels are all 16K, but covered double the area.
Ooh, much better using virtual shadow maps.
Concept, clip map levels are centered
around a clip map origin.
An example, the camera.
This is what I was talking about before.
It draws it up as needed.
Each clip map level is snapped
such that the pages fall on the grid.
This is very convenient for catching the LED fallbacks.
So you can see just by this methodology alone,
by looking how I broke this down for you,
that it works much more efficiently
and it calls upon what you need when you need it
instead of drawing everything at the same time.
Now you can see the virtual shadow maps
allow for more precise control, realism.
So let's look at this a bit more with the editor.
So in Unreal, we can go over here under light
and we can go to virtual shadow maps.
You can see we have a shadow mask here.
We can also take a look here
and look at our clip map levels,
which we were just talking about.
You'll notice it's pretty simple here, not too complex.
We also can go in here.
Again, we don't have a lot of different lights in here,
so it's a pretty much one straight light.
We have virtual page here,
shows us drawing what we need when we need it.
Pretty great.
Shows the sorting in action in real time.
And we also have catch page.
And then we also have our Nanite overdraw.
Notice we really don't have a lot of overdraw.
You see a clip a little bit in the camera
as I turn my camera around,
but overall it's doing pretty good.
You can see it kind of shift and try to find those areas,
but we're doing really well.
This is pretty simplistic scene,
but you won't see a lot of trouble
that we're gonna have in this particular case.
Let's go back to the slides.
Now out of the box,
you shouldn't have to really edit too much,
but there may be some times when you want to edit things.
So you can use the console command,
R shadow virtual SMRT, ray count local,
and you can also use R shadow virtual SMRT,
ray count directional to adjust the number of rays
in the penumbra.
Now fewer rays will give you noise.
More rays will be smoother.
Zero creates a harder shadow.
So shadow ray samples can also be adjusted
via these commands.
There's a couple more here,
sample per ray and samples per ray directional.
To adjust the number of samples used,
using values between four and eight samples works well.
So just keep that in mind.
So I'm gonna show you this real quick in Unreal.
So anytime you want to test out those,
you can use this particular tool
if you're not familiar with it.
Under windows, there's a thing called console variables.
Now, for some reason, it doesn't pop up for you.
You can go into your plugin manager
and you can type in console
and you'll see console variables
and you want to turn it on here.
Now, if you're in a game template,
that may not show up automatically.
It's definitely going to show up here
cause I already have it set up for you.
And from here, you can go ahead
and load any one of these variables.
You'll see that I have a new console variable asset
you can look at and play with.
You'll see we have some areas in here.
We have shading, rejection, flickering period.
That's a CVAR you can also use to help with that.
This prevents any weirdness with Lumen.
Now Lumen's improved a lot with the noise.
So some of these, you may not even have to use.
And you'll also notice
we have a Lumen reflection screen traces.
So you can load any one that I've given you.
There's another one called awesome,
which has a few more card placement,
which we talked about earlier,
but you can also load those ones
that I've given you in the slides.
And you can adjust things accordingly if you need to.
Now it's always good to test things out.
By default, it's going to give you
that first initial number.
And then when you punch in your number,
you can change it or send it back.
It'll actually allow you to send it back
to its original default if you need.
One thing to note is the per number has limits,
but you can extend those limits.
So just be careful with that when you do.
You want to keep that per number size reasonable,
or you will get bad shadow artifacts.
So just make sure you're consistent with your stuff
and you don't want to have any inconsistent areas.
It's going to be weird.
Virtual shadow maps now respect an anti-call distance,
even when shadow catching is enabled.
This has been around since like 5.4.
Scenes reliant on calling will now have faster shadows,
but might see shadow artifacts
if the call distance are short enough
to see popping the primary render.
You'll notice in our settings here as we type them in,
you'll see a shadow catch invalidation behavior.
Auto should work just fine.
You should be okay with that.
There's a pre primitive flag that gives the user control
over shadow invalidation behavior.
So you'll notice again, auto should be okay,
but you can change that if you need to.
Let's go and look at that briefly in Unreal.
So in Unreal, I can simply just select any piece
of geometry that I think I need to adjust shadows a bit.
And I can type in shadow CA,
and you're going to see the shadow catch
invalidation behavior.
And again, this relates when it comes
to virtual shadow maps.
The auto should work just fine,
but you have other areas
if you're getting some sort of error,
if you want to be able to adjust them accordingly.
Always invalidate shadows and can be used
to flag a primitive that is using some method
of animating that is not known to the system.
There's also rigid and suppresses the invalidations
that would otherwise generate by EG,
say world position offset can be used for example,
when they use world position offset statically used,
or the artifacts are subtle.
So you can troubleshoot if you are getting
some weird errors, but auto overall should work.
And there's also static for stuff
that's a little bit more rigid in behavior.
But again, auto should be just fine,
but you have those options to be able to play
with those within each individual object.
We also have mesh distance field editing.
For some meshes, thin surfaces may give you some errors.
So, but you can adjust those.
And we talked about this earlier.
We can go in here and you can edit them.
Now you'll notice there's an overall edit
underneath rendering in our project settings.
And we can control the distance field of voxel density.
Now by default, this should be just fine.
And most of the time you're gonna find yourself
more on a micro level of adjusting things per object
because things are gonna be different.
There's gonna be thickness variations.
There's gonna be things that will force you to be able,
hmm, I'm gonna take another look at the shadow.
This is not working out the way that I want.
So I do recommend maybe don't mess with this too much
unless you want an overall sweeping change,
but you can again go into your distance field
resolution scale and you can change things.
And you'll see there's project settings,
adjusting globally,
adjust distance field voxel density
and static mesh editor,
increasing distance field resolution scale,
which is the one that I highly recommend.
So there's two different ways that you can do so.
One's more macro, another one micro.
I like to try to go to this one first if we can,
then you can maybe revisit this one later.
And the reason why is because if you start introducing
new different shapes of geometry,
there's gonna be different needs for each one.
And starting here first might be just fine
where you don't have to do a sweeping change.
So visualizers, we'd looked at those a bit here.
So let's talk about them in more detail.
So we have a shadow mask.
It's the final shadow mask that is used by shading.
We have clip MIP level,
the chosen clip MIP for directional lights
or MIP for local lights, that level.
And we have virtual page.
This is the visualization of the virtual page addresses,
which we talked about as it flips through those
and calculates those kind of like virtual texturing
and calls it what you need when you need it.
And catch pages work similar to that.
They're tinted green, uncatch pages are red,
pages were only the static pages.
Catched and dynamic, uncatched or blue.
Now, remember these are mainly for visual representation.
You can get an idea of how things are being calculated.
Overall, you're gonna combine this with optimizing,
looking at maybe your virtual insights.
If you notice that there's some things
not working correctly, your geometry is too complex,
your lighting, you have too much going on
in a particular area, but you know,
then you can also lean on such new tools,
such as mega lights,
if you need to adjust things accordingly.
And again, you can control things in a finite level
or in a more macro level, just depends on your project
and what you're going for and how you wanna tackle it.
Well, that's it for this topic.
Here's a link here that can allow you
to jump in a bit deeper if you need to.
Feel free to ask us questions during Q and A
and let's move on to the next topic.
So in the next one,
we're gonna take a look at lighting tools overall,
looking at some of the new features
and new tools we have also coming down the pipe.
And then from there,
we'll start looking at interactively lighting a scene
in Unreal and we'll have some fun.
Thanks again.